wir sprechen über einen tiefen Politik
Sumpf offenbar und stellen uns die Frage
steckt der Kanzler steckt Olaf Scholz da
sogar mit drin in diesem Sumpf in
Hamburg ja und es geht nicht nur um den
Kanzler es geht primär um Johannes Cars
der war viele viele Jahre der
chefhaushalter in der SPD im Bundestag
mächtiger Mann ex-abgeordneter aus
Hamburg also einer der sich ums Geld
gekümmert hat und bei ihm bei ihm haben
die Ermittler nun in einem
Bankschließfach sehr viel Geld gefunden
200.000 €. was ist das für Kohle bei
Johannes Kaas woher kommt dieses Geld
alle zucken bloß mit den Schultern wo er
so viel Kohle her hat hat das was
möglicherweise mit dem cum-ex-skandal zu
tun dem Skandal der auch die Hamburger
Warburg Bank ja längst erfasst hat und
dann wird's spannend denn die beiden die
kannten sich natürlich gut Johannes Kaas
und Olaf Scholz beide Hamburg beide
mächtige Politiker dort
ist der Start und beide auch vorm
Untersuchungsausschuss dort mit Blick
auf diesen cum-ex-skandal der Kanzler
muss nächste Woche da wieder Aussagen
dann wird es spannend sein was ja auch
zum Fall Cars zu sagen hat und ob er
sich überhaupt mal wieder an was
erinnert wird bisher was im
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg ja so
bei cum-ex meistens Schuld dazu meistens
konnte man sich irgendwie komischerweise
an nichts erinnern Bild breaking news
willkommen zurück hier bei Bild live an
diesem Montag mit dem spektakulären
Feuer in Hamburg und das mitten im
Berufsverkehr mitten in Hamburg
ausgerechnet nämlich unter den so
bekannten Elbbrücken dort unter der
Bahnstrecke da hat wie sie sehen hier
ein 40 Tonner gebrannt ja der Fahrer das
ist die gute Nachricht der konnte sich
da zum Glück rausretten der Rauch aber
der war über der ganzen Stadt zu sehen
und für die Feuerwehr als mehr als nur
kompliziert dort unter der Brücke zu
löschen riesige Hitze natürlich dort ja
aber mit viel Schaum haben sie gerade
schon gesehen ist das dann am Ende
gelungen jetzt muss erstmal gecheckt
werden ob die Brücke das alles so
richtig gut überstanden hat oder ob die
vielleicht auch ein paar Risse bekommen
hat möglicherweise sogar
einsturzgefährdet ist immerhin der
Zugverkehr der war stundenlang
unterbrochen der rollt jetzt wieder und
auch der Autoverkehr gab nämlich so
richtig Verkehrschaos heute früh in der
Hansestadt wegen dieses Feuers wir
schauen auf einen wahren Freizeitpark
Horror das ganze passiert in
Rheinland-Pfalz das ist jetzt
Sommerferien das Wetter wo man in diese
Freizeitparks geht mit der Familie aber
dann passiert dort an dieser Achterbahn
das seine Frau aus dem Saarland die
fliegt plötzlich bei voller Fahrt raus
aus dieser Achterbahn das was wirklich
ein Albtraum ist absoluter Albtraum die
57-Jährige die fliegt aus ihrem Sitz
stürzt Meter tief zu Boden und stirbt
ein Zeuge erhebt jetzt schwere Vorwürfe
sie suchte den Nervenkitzel und fand den
Tod es ist der Albtraum für jeden
Freizeitpark Besucher bei voller Fahrt
fliegt eine Frau in Rheinland-Pfalz aus
der Achterbahn der Horror-Unfall
passiert im wild- und Freizeitpark
Klotten in Rheinland-Pfalz direkt an der
idyllischen Mosel eine der größten
Attraktionen des Parks die heiße Fahrt
eine 532 m lange Achterbahn mit einer
Höhe von 17,5 m am Samstag ist die
57-Jährige aus St wendel im Saarland mit
ihrer Familie zu Besuch im Park sie
steigt in die Achterbahn freut sich auf
die aufregende Fahrt auf rasante Kurven
und Rausch der Geschwindigkeit und dann
das plötzlich fliegt die Frau aus ihrem
Sitz stürzt mehrere Meter tief und
prallt auf den Boden
Einsatzkräfte Island zum wild und
Freizeitpark an der Mosel doch für die
57-Jährige kommt jede Hilfe zu die Frau
stirbt an ihren schweren Verletzungen
der Horror-Unfall in Rheinland-Pfalz vom
Wochenende kein Einzelfall immer wieder
kommt es in Freizeitparks zu tragischen
Unfällen einige Enten tödlich erst Mitte
Juli stirbt bei einem schweren Unfall in
einer Achterbahn im dänischen Aarhus ein
14-jähriges Mädchen im September 2021
stürzt eine sechsjährige aus einer
Achterbahn in einem Freizeitpark im
US-Bundesstaat Colorado und kommt ums
Leben wie konnte der schreckliche Unfall
in Rheinland-Pfalz am Wochenende
passieren war es ein technischer Defekt
oder grobe Fahrlässigkeit das ist jetzt
Gegenstand von Ermittlung ein Fahrgast
der am Samstag vor Ort war sagt
gegenüber Bild das vor der Fahrt
offenbar die Sicherheitsbügel nicht
ausreichend kontrolliert wurden
kurvenreich maximales Gefälle und bis zu
60 Stundenkilometer schnell so bewerben
Betreiber die Achterbahn auf ihrer
Internetseite die Fahrt nichts für
Angsthasen heißt es die Achterbahn mit
dem Namen die heiße Fahrt wie wurde zur
tödlichen Fahrt die Suche nach
Nervenkitzel für die Frau aus St wendel
endete die tödlich
ja und jetzt suchen die Ermittler den
ganzen Tag nach der Ursache für diese
schreckliche Unglück unser Bild Reporter
Jonathan ander ist dort bei den
Ermittlern im gerade schon gehört die
Sicherheitsbügel die sollen eine ganze
entscheidende Rolle gespielt haben denn
man denkt ja immer da kann eigentlich
nichts passieren das wird dauernd
überprüft hier möglicherweise nicht
Jonathan
ja das ist gerade Gegenstand der
Ermittlungen es wird in alle Richtungen
ermittelt ob ja da möglicherweise die
Sicherheitsbügel nicht ausreichend
kontrolliert wird wurden laut einem
Zeugen mit dem wir am Samstag gesprochen
hatten der auch dort war kurz bevor
dieses Unglück passiert war mit seiner
Tochter
da diese Achterbahn gefahren ist der
sagte die Sicherheitsbügel sein nicht
richtig kontrolliert worden sagte auch
was besonders
schlimm ist dass diese Frau da
rausgeflogen sei und erstmal gesucht
werden musste also da das so ein
unbetretbares schwieriges Gebiet das ist
hügelig da ist überall Wald also die die
Rettungskräfte mussten erstmal die Frau
suchen und haben sie dann von noch
versucht wieder zu beleben also der
blanke Achterbahn Horror spielte sich
hier hinter mir ab mittlerweile hat auch
der Parkbetreiber auf seiner Website zu
Wort gemeldet und hat sein tiefes
Bedauern ausgedrückt hat gesagt die
gesamte Belegschaft ist schockiert und
und fassungslos und ja alles weitere
wird wird sich jetzt über den über den
Tag
herausstellen der Park auf jeden Fall
ist ja geschlossen und bleibt
geschlossen bis auf weiteres nehme ich
an
ja gestern war die Ansage dass gestern
geschlossen werden sollte aufgrund
Betrieb einem schwerwiegenden
betrieblichen Grund heute wird man da
schon konkreter und spricht von einem
tödlichen Unfall auch heute ist der Park
geschlossen und auch heute werden hier
die Ermittler den genauen Gründen
nachgehen erstmal niemand antun da hat
ein achterbahnpark ohne benutzbare
Achterbahn danke Jonathan an da unser
Bild Reporter dort nach diesem
schrecklichen achterbahnunfall drei Tage
haben palästinensische Terroristen
Raketen aus Gaza in Richtung Israel
abgefeuert jetzt haben beide Seiten
einer Feuerpause zugestimmt diese
Waffenruhe sozusagen die ist in der
Nacht um 22 Uhr unserer Zeit in Kraft
getreten ja nur wenige Stunden zuvor
waren am Sonntagabend Sirenen in Tel
Aviv zu hören Zivilisten hasteten in
Schutzräume vieler erzählten von dumpfen
Explosionen die zu hören waren insgesamt
haben die Palästinenser Terroristen seit
Freitag knapp 1000 Raketen gefeuert ja
bei einem Luftschlag hat die Israel
zuvor den Top-Terroristen Teil sehr Bari
ausgeschaltet und wir gehen ins Land wir
gehen nach Tel Aviv zu unserer
bildreporterin Antonia Jamin Antonia ich
grüße dich und wir wollen natürlich
heute nachdem wir gerade gehört haben
mehr als tausend Raketen wissen wie
stabil diese ausgehandelte Waffenruhe
ist oder sein könnte
ja guten Morgen Kai also ich muss so
sagen da Waffenstillstand ist ja gestern
22 Uhr deutsche Zeit eingedreht und es
hat genau acht Minuten gedauert bis der
islamische Dschihad die nächste Rakete
schon auf Israel geschossen hat also so
stabil ist es aber tatsächlich war die
Nacht relativ ruhig ich muss sagen ich
bin jetzt nicht wirklich ruhig ins Bett
gegangen so ein Waffenstillstand ist
niemals wirklich hundert Prozent man
weiß nie wer auf der anderen Seite ist
und werden dann wieder eine Rakete
abschießt man kann auch jetzt sehen ich
stehe jetzt gerade in Tel Aviv man kann
auch den Strand sehen wir sind ja im
August es gibt Sommerferien eigentlich
dieser Strand ist in einer normale Zeit
eigentlich komplett voll mit Leute mit
Familien mit Kindern und mit Touristen
und man kann jetzt sehen dass dieser
Strand sehr sehr leer ist es sollte
jetzt vorbei sein aber in Vorteil ist
niemals wirklich irgendwas vorbei und
ich sag mal so meine Einschätzung in
paar Monate gibt es hier wieder noch mal
so ein kleiner Krieg oder sogar ein
großer Krieg
du sagst es ist niemals ganz vorbei man
kennt dort den Tel Aviv diese Ausnahme
Situation dennoch in 55 Stunden Antonia
tausend Raketen wie hast du das erlebt
wie hat sich das alles für dich
angefühlt was konntest du beobachten
also in Israel lebt man ganz normal und
plötzlich passiert das und alle
verstehen dass es das ist Alarm ist ich
muss sagen ich war gestern selber in Tel
Aviv mit der Waffenstillstand sollte
eigentlich 20 Uhr eintreten fünf Minuten
vor 20 Uhr Alarm mitten in Tel Aviv alle
Leute mussten sofort zum Schutzraum
Rennen da waren Frauen da waren Kinder
da war eine Frau mit dem Baby ich selber
wurde ich bin ja jetzt Mutter das war
ich im letzten Krieg noch nicht und
plötzlich sehe ich da diese Mutter mit
ihrem Baby das die hat es so umarmt
quasi wenn irgendwas passiert das ist
das Kind nicht trifft und das war schon
auch für mich persönlich war es
plötzlich anders weil der Krieg vor
sechs Jahren zu caitan der war 51 Tagen
ich war ich war sehr oft draußen ich
habe das alles gesehen aber ich hatte
noch keine Kinder damals und plötzlich
auch als Mutter es ist total anders das
zu sehen aber
auf der andere Seite kann man auch sagen
dass es sehr viel Solidarität auf den
Straßen von Israel gibt in diesen Zeiten
sofort wenn Alarm ist dann sieht man wie
Leute ihre Häuser aufmachen und Leute
von der Straße rufen kommt kommt rein
kommt in uns ein Schutzraum nur damit
alle okay sind dank Gott ist iron Dom
hier im Einsatz und hat auch wirklich
96% Erfolg gehabt also die Raketen sind
fast nicht eingetroffen und das ist
einfach ein Wunder unsere
bild-reporterin Antonia Jamin du bist
jetzt auch plötzlich im israelischen
Fernsehen aufgetaucht es gibt eine
Artikel von Bild über den plötzlich das
ganze Land spricht
genau ich muss sagen Bild ist jetzt
gerade die beliebteste Zeitung in Israel
kein Scherz und der Grund einfach weil
Bild die Wahrheit gesagt hat gestern
erschien ein Artikel bei Bild indem man
einfach die Wahrheit sagt indem man
erzählt hat darüber dass eine
palästinensische Rakete vom Dschihad von
dem islamischen Dschihad die wollten auf
Israel schießen haben es aber nicht
geschafft und diese Rakete ist leider
muss man auch so sagen in
Gaza eingetroffen und hat da Kinder
umgebracht die ist also die Islam die
der dschihadische Islam wollte sofort
Propaganda machen und hat versucht zu
sagen dass es eine israelische Rakete
war der IDF die israelische Armee hatten
sofort die Bilder und haben gezeigt dass
es nicht eine israelische Rakete war
sondern eine palästinensische Rakete
Bild hat es auch so groß gemacht war
eine der einzigen
medienoutletten quasi auf der Welt das
ist so schnell aufgedeckt haben und ähm
und die Israelis waren erstaunt weil
hier in Israel ist man wirklich dran
gewohnt das international die
palästinensische Propaganda sehr sehr
stark ist und davor hat man hier gestern
Bild sehr sehr gelobt
Antonia Jamin vielen herzlichen Dank für
deine Informationen aus Tel Aviv
werden Israel die einzige Demokratie da
im Nahen Osten um seine Sicherheit
kämpft spielen sich hier in Deutschland
wieder beschämende Szenen ab 55 Minuten
purer Hass gegen Israel mitten in Berlin
wir sind das mittlerweile ja schon fast
gewohnt immer und immer wieder diesmal
sie sehen das hier am Potsdamer Platz
200 Menschen haben sich dort versammelt
schwenken palästinensische fahren und
brüllen dann auch Parolen wie wir haben
das Gerede vom friedlich seinen satt wir
werden Raketen abfeuern und diese
Parolen die werden dann beklatscht und
begeistert wiederholt und das verteilst
du die Redner auf der Bühne die feiern
dann die Terrorgruppen wie den
islamischen Spezial fährt hinterher
sehen Sie hier mit Blaulicht gleiche
Szenerie in Stuttgart gestern auch dort
sind 80 Menschen da durch die Straßen
gezogen und haben den Terror gegen
Israel dort beklatscht und bejubelt irre
sehen die Polizei ja fährt hinterher und
offenbar alles gedul nächste Reaktion
werden wieder Politiker sein die sagen
das dürfen wir alles nicht das müssen
wir verhindern das muss sich alles
ändern und ja wir sehen uns auf den
Straßen es ändert sich einfach nicht
immer wieder
anti-israeldemonstrationen hier bei uns
in Deutschland sie ist nicht zurück sie
ist zurückgetreten rbb Intendanten
Patricia Schlesinger die Vorwürfe
zahlreich unter anderem ging es um von
Bild in allen Details enthüllte
luxuriöse Umbauten ihres Büros ein
dienstwagen-skandal und aus
Rundfunkgebühren bezahlte sogenannte
Dienst Essen in ihrer Privatwohnung
der 13 Stock der rbb-zentrale mitten in
Berlin hier arbeitet Sie Patricia
Schlesinger Intendanten des Rundfunk
Berlin-Brandenburg ein bis ins kleinste
Detail durch designter Arbeitsplatz
bezahlt mit Rundfunkgebühren nach dem
Einzug in die Intendanten Etage hat
Patricia Schlesinger den Umbau in
Auftrag gegeben nach Bildinformation ein
Umbau der wenig Wünsche offen lässt hier
ein Einblick in die opulente
Bestellliste als erstes ließ Schlesinger
von einer Berliner Manufaktur den
Teppichboden rausreißen knapp 75
Quadratmeter und mit feinsten Parkett
auslegen Marke caboeva padro select
ökologisches hochwertiges italienisches
zwei schichtparkett vorgeölt vom
Hersteller mazoneto neaps Sockelleisten
und erst Pfleger Preis knapp 17.000 Euro
besonders auffällig weil der Fußboden
während Schlesingers bevorstehenden
Urlaub verlegt werden sollte wurde in
der Vorschriften keine weiteren Angebote
eingeholt die in Revision monierte das
wurde aber überstimmt Auszug aus dem
Beschluss nach Rücksprache mit Frau
Schlesinger so beauftragen im August
2021 bestätig Schlesinger für Ihr Büro
ein Massage-Sessel Vitalis Shiatsu mit
Wärmefunktion rollbar drehbar Farbe
creme für 1299 Euro plus 60 Euro Versand
für knapp 7.660 Euro ließ sich
Schlesinger im August 2019 eine mit
Pflanzen begrünte Wand mit automatischer
Bewässerung von der Berliner Firma von
Nature System in ihrem Leitungsbereich
einbauen doch es wird noch protziger
knapp 60.000 Euro kostet die neue
Möbelierung die im Juli 2021 mit Blick
auf die bevorstehende Übernahme des
ard-vorsitzes von der Berliner Filiale
der Firma Design function angeschafft
wurde unter anderem ein altkauf kabin
3-Sitzer Highback für 12.161 Euro 2
vitra-einkauf Highback 3-Sitzer für
zusammen
10.612 Euro 6 core Drop Barhocker
stapelbar für gesamt
3642 Euro insgesamt sind für den Umbau
der Chefetage für den ard-vorsitz laut
Projekt des rbb Gebäudemanagements knapp
700.000 Euro veranschlagt worden
also Selbstbedienung der offenbar beim
rbb in der Chefetage wir sprechen mit
Ralf Schuler dem Chef unseres
parlamentsbüros ohne Massagesessel bei
uns im Studio Ralf grüße dich herzlich
jetzt ist Patricia Schlesinger Weg hat
sie angekündigt zumindest aber auch der
Abschied könnten noch mal teuer werden
wie das so ist bei spitzenverträgen hat
sie gesagt ja ich wäre bereit mein
Posten zur Verfügung zu stellen hat aber
auf Klauseln in Ihrem Vertrag verwiesen
die darauf hindeuten dass sie entweder
die komplette Summe sie ist bis 2026
gewählt ausgezahlt haben möchte das
wären dann rund 1,2 Millionen Euro es
kann auch sein dass der Anwalt ein
Angebot gemacht hat eine Abfindung
darunter irgendwie auszuhandeln aber
dass sie ihn offenbar noch Geld
mitnehmen möchte das ist eigentlich
relativ klar
also da richtet man sich alles schön ein
auf Kosten unserer Gebühren sozusagen
macht sich schön die Chefetage dann wird
man gefeuert und dann sagt man so im
moment mal jetzt hätte ich eigentlich
gerne noch ein bisschen Geld wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn dass sie so
eine Summe erhält und Ralfi war es
überhaupt möglich dass das alles
passieren konnte man sollte annehmen da
ist irgendeine Art Kontrolle Überwachung
also das irgendjemand das im Blick hat
absolut aus diese Abfindung kommen ja
aus den Gebühren das muss man sich halt
immer klar machen es ist im
Geschäftsleben nicht ganz unüblich dass
man spitzenverträge mit
abfindungsklauseln versieht bzw mit
Klauseln dass man auch bei vorfristiger
Beendigung noch den Rest mitnehmen kann
wenn es um öffentliche Gelder geht ist
das ein bisschen
anrüch ich muss man dann schon sagen und
das große Problem was auch noch dahinter
steckt ist ja nicht nur die Tatsache
dass sie sich großzügig da die Chefetage
eingerichtet hat sondern das eben auch
die Prüfgremien versagt haben es ist
leider im öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk seit Jahren so dass auch die
Rundfunkgeräte die eigentlich
kontrollieren wollen dann gerne mal
Karten in der ersten Reihe bei Wetten
Dass oder anderen großen Shows bekommen
oder das gute Berichte aus den
jeweiligen Regionen der Rundfunkgeräte
in den Sendern auftauchen und dass man
da eigentlich ganz gut miteinander
auskommt die Kontrolle funktioniert
nicht das ist eigentlich das ganz große
Problem und das dritte was sich an
dieser Affäre gezeigt hat diese ganzen
Informationen über die Anschaffung von
vorschlesinger und auch über die
gezinkten Rechnungen sie hat tatsächlich
angewiesen dass die Geschäftsessen die
Personenzahl auf der Rechnung reduziert
wird das hat Business Insider aufgedeckt
dass all dieses möglich ist zeigt dass
sie ein Regime geführt hat was dazu
führt dass aus dem Haus heraus diese
ganzen Informationen nach außen gelangt
sind einfach weil man diese Chefin nicht
mehr wollte das ist das andere Problem
also da ist sehr sehr viel aufzuräumen
beim rbb bei der RBB und in der ARD
Fragezeichen ist der Rücktritt von
Patricia Schlesinger jetzt das Zeichen
Problem löst oder gibt es sprichwörtlich
gesagt noch überall in vielen Ländern in
vielen Rundfunkanstalten noch diese
Massage Sessel da müsste man mal genauer
hingucken ich glaube das war ein
besonders schwerer Fall von
Selbstbedienung was insofern interessant
ist Frau Schlesinger hat ja lange Zeit
das investigativ-magazin des
Norddeutschen Rundfunks geleitet ihr
Mann der auch bei den Geschäftsessen
immer dabei war war auch investigativ
Journalist beim Spiegel sie haben
eigentlich genau das gemacht was sie
Jahre vorher niemandem in der Politik
hätten durchgehen lassen und dann auch
die gleichen Mechanismen gezogen sie
tritt erst vom ard-vorsitz zurück möchte
dann aber ihren gut bezahlten Posten
doch noch behalten dann tritt sie zurück
sagt es ist eine üble Hetzkampagne es
ist keine Hetzkampagne gewesen auch Bild
hat nur zitiert aus den internen
Berichten der Anschaffung und dieses
Kontrollsystem was ich gerade
angesprochen habe das haben wir in der
Tat bei der gesamten ARD ich glaube
nicht dass ich in dem Maße andere
Intendanten auch bereichern aber man
muss einfach genau hingucken dass die
Kontrolle und der effiziente zusammen
mit den gebührenmitteln dass der einfach
irgendwie eingehalten wird und nicht
durch Kungeleien zwischen den
Aufsichtsgremien durchrutscht Ralf
Schuller vielen herzlichen Dank für
diese Hintergrundinformationen zu diesem
Thema
[Musik]